all things to keep an eye on as uh
kyle hendricks gets things set sugo
plenty of power
there's another one down the line and
sutsugo hits one off the scoreboard in
right his sixth home run with the
pirates in just 38 at bats the former
japanese league home run champ they love
him there and they love him all
throughout the states as well the way
that he's been hitting with the pirates
takes care of stalin's his first
strikeout two down
one thousandth strikeout of kyle's
career it's for jt for a sixth win and
lower that era once again a little more
than a strikeout printing also picked up
a win in his last start over arizona and
ortega will beat the shift send it the
other way in the lead off for rafael his
third hit of the series
and that'll drop him
back-to-back hits to open things up for
the cubs you have 18 homers 44 rbis pick
off try and they got them
kevin newman
snuck in and applied the tag of ortega
who is still on the bag resting on one
knee at the moment looking toward his
dugout asking them to
look at it he thinks he's safe so will
they challenge andy green is the acting
manager david ross tested positive for
covid yesterday they will not challenge
the pick off works and it goes 1-6
and he strikes out ian half and that's a
nice pitch
and he strikes out contreras
great job by brubacher first two men
reach
he strikes out the last two
well for average power
over the mound and he can run
gonna be a tough play oh yeah
finds himself a base hit that was a
toughy for duffy and beat it easily i
mean wasn't even close i mean i thought
i thought there'd be a play it'd be
definitely a play but off the end of the
bat out of the box quickly duffy
not nearly quick enough
runners on the corners here with two
down
gets a hold of this one ortega on the
run in center long way to go forward and
he tracks it down
a couple of steps out of the dirt for
raphael
outstanding play
outstanding play
and coming off the bat he had to run
that ball down
full stride
good timing
and total confidence in corralling that
2-2 pitch swing and a miss struck him
out with another slider and that's three
punch house now for brubacher
brings up jason hayward
and he strikes him out with the
curveball
four strikeouts for jt brubacher
and he and the pirates working with a
one-nothing lead so much of the unknown
about going from
a 60 game schedule and very few winnings
for most pitchers last year to a full
season once again
there's a strike three called back to
the top in ortega singled in the first
and then got picked off of second base
hard hit shot looking for the gap and
he'll find it
into the ivy out in right center and the
double for ortega standing
well he's off a good start despite being
picked off he's two for two and he's
made a spectacular play in the outfield
that saved at least one run look at the
6'5 cubs win
a little roller
and defoe collects it in time for the
final out brubaker keeps the cubs off
the board again brubaker deals the pitch
is pulled fair ball down the right field
line it'll roll bouncing off the
sideline as half cruises into second
base with a lead-off double here in the
fourth now you gotta like ian jumping on
that first pitch and he has been
much more aggressive here in the last
week week and a half at the plate
and in particular on the first couple
pitches if he gets something good to get
he hooks this ball right past moran it
hits the sidewall and kicks out
happer as we know with great speed ends
up for the lead off double
tried to paint with the heater
couple on with nobody out
first free pass issued by brubacher
that one gets away from stallings and
the runners will move up
two in scoring position with nobody out
let's see how they score it jd yeah
that'll be a long one
sam howard coming on
a couple of rough outings got that era
up still tough to hit
we're hoping that jt brubaker is okay
back-to-back walks from two different
pitchers and here's matt duffy with the
bases loaded struck out in the second
but that was against brubacher and this
is howard
and that will get through and a run will
score as hat comes home
contreras had to keep an eye on it he
will hold it third
and duffy ties it up with a base hit and
it's jason hayward who struck out on a
curve ball in the second
here's the one-two
for the right side miranda second for
one that's all they'll get
and contreras comes in to score for the
lead
counter a high chopper and that will get
another one home
pirates get the second out at first as
wisdom scores and it's 3-1 codes
and strike three hendricks is gone but
the cubs score three times get a 3-1
lead through four innings tucker a
couple of bounce outs today pirates
getting the lead off man aboard
rope to right base hit
evans gets to second two on nobody out
for yoshi tsutsugo
cap will give it a look and we'll track
it down
runners will have to hold one out
looking for his first hit of the year
with the bases loaded
and another off the plate he walked in a
run three walks in the inning for
hendricks he hasn't walked more than
three in a game in years
anthony offered two home runs yesterday
it hit him
the game's time this is the wildest i've
ever seen hendrickson in inning here
comes mcgill the numbers overall not
good 15 innings in a 960 era last couple
times out though he's thrown the ball
well
gets away
and a run is in stallings scores to give
the pirates the lead again with second
and third and one out
on the ground and through moran is in
alford being waved home
and he will score
the pirates with two more off the bat of
defoe
i love it baby take that there's frank
schwendel single in the first grounded
out in the third
towering blast
schwendell
scoreboard gone
frank the tank does the sloppy swish
my
goodness
this is a fun fun story folks
29 year old frank schwendell getting a
chance at the big leagues
and doing it upright
wow how do you get to that that's going
to drop
that's a beauty right there that's
fastball off the plate and up with the
hands in
paris shoot it in the left but one two
called strike three that one nipped the
outside corner of the plate two away
little bounding ball that gets through
and phillip evans has a hit got the call
back up for september
as his first hit since coming on back
and the strikeout of tucker
two down
got him brothers back-to-back strikeouts
let's see if the heart of the cubs order
can do some damage need a pair
intensity shook to the fastball
interesting target
nope can't beat him
tortoise wins the race again if
stillings is the cheetah then that guy's
the tortoise yep that's getting down the
line two infield hits today
two homers yesterday
he's running
two stolen bases today wow
yeah anthony alford can do it all
got him scott frost with the strikeout
to end the threat last chance coming up
for the cubbies
he's already had an 11 out save this
year as stratton
here we go base hit inside the bag and
that will bring the tying run to the
plate
contra has a base hit today
draws the walk and the
tying run now aboard and the winning run
to the plate
rivas
trying to drop that one down he finds
some grass duffy around third to score
alcantara to hold it third
rbi single for rivas and it's a one run
game
as ortega steps in
[Applause]
ortega
and that one will fall out of the glove
of gamble tying run is in romine will
hold it
as the throw came in behind him at
second base on their feet at wrigley
looking for a second walk off
in this series
schwindel
deep in the hole long throw over to the
bag at first and he slides in safe as
andrew romine scores
cups celebrate there will be a review
well swindle probably knows as well as
anyone if that tag
landed but great instincts to be able to
dive
and really get under it let's see does
he touch him here we go
[Applause]
cubs win with their second walk off in
three days